Michelle Turner here now with another
major interview with Jennifer Hudson
absolutely she doesn't do many
interviews when she joined her sister
Julia this weekend at an annual event in
honor of Julia Sun that remember he was
murdered in 2008 along with their mother
and their brother but Jennifer and Julia
had turned their unspeakable family
tragedy oh don't worry my sister to be
able to look for it to her son's
birthdays or Christmas it was a loss of
unfathomable proportion on one day
Jennifer lost her mother her brother and
her 7 year old nephew Julian all shot
dead in Jennifer's hometown of Chicago
by her estranged brother-in-law who is
now in prison for years
Jennifer couldn't bring herself to talk
about the loss my mother always told me
Jenny what I love about you is no matter
how negative things are you always seem
to find a positive but finding the
positive wasn't easy and satisfied Wow
what if we gave to the children of
Chicago been there for so six years ago
the two sisters came up with an idea to
turn the family's tragedy into a triumph
of the Spirit every year on Julian's
birthday or what he liked to call hatch
day they celebrate his life by donating
school supplies to thousands of children
in need in the community
so I guess Julian was a scholar of a
child you know as a student and he was a
giver as well so hatch day represents
everything about him the program started
in a church basement has now grown to
being able to help over 5,000 children
get ready for school I had no idea what
we were starting and so to think back
then to now it's like look at the seat
we have plenty it means a lot to be able
to help to give back and while
Jennifer's making a difference in the
lives of thousands of Chicago
schoolchildren she's also looking
forward to her next big project
hairspray live we just did a table read
for it recently and I was
completely blown away by the cast it is
an amazing cast and I'm just excited to
just be a part of it so it's going to be
a great experience make sure you guys
watch December 7th on NBC yeah but it's
gonna be good